Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at if it
is actually possible for a human or small
group of humans to push a standing cow over.
Let's get started.
For the uninitiated, cow tipping is a prank
where a person sneaks up on a sleeping cow
and pushes the animal over onto its side.
Ask around and you can probably hear about
a friend of a friend who successfully tipped
a cow while out in the country late one night.
The story generally recounts participants
having a few alcoholic drinks before driving
to a cow pasture and setting upon a slumbering
bovine.
But is it really possible to tip a cow?
Well, anything is possible and humans are
quite inventive, but in the way that cow tipping
is generally depicted- no, it is not possible
to tip a sleeping cow.
The first issue here is that cows don’t
actually sleep while standing up, at least
not in the way we tend to think of sleep.
Cows do sometimes enter a sort of restful
state while standing up, but while in this
state they are easily startled and are reasonably
well aware of what’s going on around them.
Their deep sleep state occurs while they are
already lying down (something they do for
about 14 hours per day, with a few hours of
that time in a deep sleep; the rest of the
time they’re either awake or in their light-resting
state).
Another issue with the idea of sneaking up
on a cow that is resting while standing is
that at any given time in a herd of cattle,
a number of the cows are wide awake.
Cows may be largely domesticated animals today,
but they still retain their flight instinct
when they suspect a predator is nearby or
observe others in the herd that appear startled
by something.
One cow will very quickly, via their behavior,
alert the others in the herd if they hear
or see anything suspicious, causing the others
to in turn become on edge and alert.
Given a standing cow that is resting is very
easily startled from its resting state, even
without any other cows around, this makes
the idea of sneaking up on one of these cows
even more difficult, if not impossible.
But let’s say you and your friends manage
to somehow park your car within walking distance
of a cow without alerting it (harder than
you think on a quiet country night, even parking
a couple miles away), then you manage to hop
the barbed wire fence and creep up to said
cow without startling it or any other cows
in the herd via sound, sight, or your scent.
In that increasingly unlikely scenario, would
you physically have the strength to tip the
cow?
Dr. Margo Lillie and Tracy Boechler of the
zoology department at the University of British
Columbia conducted a study in 2005 to figure
out the answer to this very question.
Lillie and Boechler determined that it would
take approximately 1,360 to 2,910 Newtons
of force applied at the optimal angle to tip
an average cow.
(For reference, an average full grown Holstein
dairy cow typically weighs in at around 1,500
lbs, though this can vary by a few hundred
pounds depending on a variety of factors).
They then estimated that an average adult
human could generate approximately 660 Newtons
of force at the optimal tipping angle.
So in theory, on the low end with a completely
static cow, approximately two people could
apply enough force to tip said static cow.
The problem is that a cow would most certainly
not stay static in such a scenario.
And heaven help you if you tried to push over
an 1800 to 2000+ pound bull.
(And note, people don’t generally survive
being attacked by such bulls, which is probably
what would happen if you tried sneaking up
on one and attempted tipping it over.)
So, on the high end, according to Dr. Lillie,
overcoming the non-static cow’s ability
to brace itself would require in the optimal
scenario around five people.
But even if you did this, there is the fact
that a cow in a state of falling is generally
perfectly agile enough to simply catch itself
and trot away.
In the end, while it is technically possible
for a group of humans to devise a way to cause
a cow to tip over, it is, in the practical
sense, impossible in the way generally illustrated
when stereotypically inebriated individuals
are described as tipping cows.
So where did the idea of cow tipping come
from?
Unfortunately, the answer is that no one knows
for sure.
It has been theorized that the practice of
attempting cow tipping probably came about
via serving the same function as so called
game of snipe hunting- sending a gullible
individual out to perform some impossible
task for the amusement of those in the know.
(Although it should be noted that this is
a potentially very dangerous snipe hunting
style game, particularly if there is a bull
around in the herd.)
As for how this particular “game” entered
the mainstream, stories of it began popping
up in the late 20th century and it particularly
gained steam thanks to such movies as the
1989 Heathers and the 1995 Tommy Boy, along
with the 1994 Season 4 episode of Beavis and
Butthead titled “Cow Tipping” where the
duo failed in their attempt at tipping a horse,
then were successful at tipping a cow which
landed on Beavis.
More recently, the 2006 Pixar film Cars depicts
Mater and Lightning tipping cow-like tractors.
Bonus Fact:
An average beef cow contains about 200 kg
of usable meat, which in turn produces enough
meat to make about 4,500 hamburgers at McDonald’s.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it, please click that like button below
and consider sharing it with anyone you think
might be interested . We’re a relatively
new channel, so that helps us out ton.
And of course if you’re new to TodayIFoundOut,
don’t forget to click the subscribe button
to get more interesting videos like this.
We release a new video almost every single
day, so you’re sure to find something you
find interesting.
Thanks for watching.